hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome let's play disco dance ball
robot roller derby this game is
something else completely and oh man is
it fun like I've been playing it for
about thirty minutes straight before
even I realized that I needed to record
it um it's in alpha right now but it's
trying to get on Steam greenlight but
god damn if you love dodgeball growing
up as a kid just playing a gym you're
gonna love this one
so anyway it's pretty simple as it
starts on there's a multiplayer mode but
there's not enough players right now to
play with so right now if that was not a
good example of what you're supposed to
do what you're supposed to do is not get
hit the wall dodge dipped up dive dodge
dodge throw another dodge in there just
because okay so the game is pretty
simplistic but I mean it's executing
it's digit so you can catch throw it's
dodgeball with robots and possibly other
players but right now these are just
literally robots so try to not talk for
a bit and show up I'm yeah you can catch
them in midair if you're really good
like me maybe yeah yeah I thought I have
it yeah yeah
and they can catch your balls as well so
if that wasn't clear everything applies
to everyone right now our team's not
doing wonderful but you I won my other
games Crump's Wow you can hold down to
all that Jess we're trending up good
sunny through that okay excuse me
bye but no threat if they don't have a
ball Isis this game it's just so much
fun this is pure unadulterated fun and
the soundtrack is bangin I thought that
guy was gonna throw it right at me
sometimes he uh yeah I doesn't make a
whole lot of sense
other times they're unbelievably precise
and can kill you from way too far away
but just got to keep your eyes open
okay I think our team is doing
relatively good but ah I can never get
those long shots no needham oh and by
the way did I mention that we all have
mustaches that's an important feature
come now
yes think he's right
Dayang it's a bit stress inducing and
I'm not even playing against other
players but this might actually be the
first multiplayer team that I would ever
play other players games yeah
Oh bounce admit it guys where to go
where to go with you ah boom [ __ ] oh I
got one big boom ah yeah yeah baby Wow
damn it and make it do cool tricks like
that and jump off in midair let me see
if I can I can do this move called where
you dunk on someone you literally jump
over them and slam the ball into their
face hey no oh come on I forgot that the
balls are still active so long as
they're colored they can bounce off a
like one or two surfaces and then they
can still kill you
Oh to jump you hold down your doobie and
you uh come ha ha you dick he denied me
you son of a [ __ ] yeah these up
sometimes zai are a bit irrational but
other times they're just kinda good
yes ok no no not now give me one nope
nope background got you [ __ ] you think
of me now
Oh long shot oh that object got in the
way
staircase thing yeah that was not
supposed oh how did I miss that
I'm such an a-hole damn hell away from
me Seth I don't know who's winning on
the other team Oh God
spits aw come on you can also have a
boost that makes you go faster obviously
and you can slam on your brakes to stop
us if you see a ball coming towards you
and you're going the wrong direction
oh god this is getting difficult
okay now one now [ __ ] like I said this
game is pure just fun yeah Oh Zeebo
sucked on that one job and cheer on the
catches yeah
alright oh I did hit everyone
okay so that was deathmatch I'm gonna
just check I haven't seen if there's any
other game on I literally think that
only right now in the mate or the alpha
release early access whatever you want
to call it there's deathmatch so I'm
just gonna play one more round because
there's so much fun and this soundtrack
I don't even listen to music but look at
this like you can't deny this is pretty
cool
sure I jumped over it ramped over it or
something
Wow god I've never played on this map
before cheerily oh you got in the way
Dave
soon all right team seems to be winning
this one quite Ken Wow
what did he have like three balls it's
not fair that's irregular three balls Oh
God Ram I didn't on my boost oh yeah you
gotta let your boost recharge a bit
before you go obviously we just unfair
if you can just get over them all mitr
hmm just want to mess with any of this
come on Michael
Oh what attack where'd you get a ball
god damn you can also play um there is a
free version of it available on the game
website it's not very uh very
graphically impressive Whitten time
again I mean either this or just robot
blocks but I mean still it's it's fully
functional it's pretty much the same
gameplay just a few tweaks here and
there so if you want if you don't want
to pay the five bucks to get early
access hello you can play that one for
free silly I'm coming for you baby hit
me [ __ ] oh so kill someone through the
midair it's gonna be sweet oh okay it's
app Oh Seth you [ __ ]
come on no no no aah ease it out oh ha
ha ha ha what say coming for you baby
dude boats oh come on
hmm
hahaha yeah yeah can you just tell like
it's up oh I thought it died forcing
this is it's just fun I mean these these
are just pawns but I mean it's still
yeah so rewarding experience this map
it's just a little funky oh come on come
on
you want somebody set you've been
dodging me all day do you know Michael
what do you do you lurk oh I said you
were gonna keep going give me give me
give me if you did Oh Seth you want some
of this oh yeah come on Seth you [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] yeah gasps please
god damn it can't seem to kill Seth huh
but her team is winning by a lot so let
me try some cool tricks
Oh No game on oh let me get Seth let me
get Seth go you [ __ ] recessed fast son
of a [ __ ] I was gonna kill you okay
let's hear them I didn't even get first
place on my team huh all right one more
I'm fun to do one more so badly we're
the balls no no no no I'm the kitchen Oh
suck on that Shore down
oh god this one isn't if this one has
even more ramps Jonathan your moon Oh
Carl okay I changed my mind I totally
meant to hit Carl there that was
completely 100% attention ah oh why
didn't they go fast
blue shoes off boost it out Japan oh man
back hair race suck on some of this oh
he's stuck the counts that counts it
totally counts totally fair oh god John
okay all right remember these are BOTS
but even though they have human names
and they look awfully human surplus key
oh damn it we're whoo was that a red
ball that I almost died from team so
what is it ah oh I don't know if you can
now what are you doing
you coming from Johnny boy is it oh my
god oh my god those way too close oh
come here
teams lose him ah come here
think I've got the only points on our
team Oh Carl keeps getting stuck I feel
bad
oh well I really don't feel that did
true where you going where you going
where you up will you ah if it looks
like I'm having fun I really am this
game is amazing sure there is a shield
when you come out of the gate so you
can't get hit right away but it only
lasts for like two seconds so don't
count on it
hey Carl gonna get stuck again Carl who
I'm asking
ah come on Carl come back here from
markup daddy oh that's a weird name huh
oh you're dodging up you got aah
you son of a [ __ ] Carl payback for all
those times you got stuck and I took
advantage of the day Oh Carl
get you Johnny boy Oh Carl
oh he's stuck I'll take advantage of it
coz we are losing all my teammates kind
of suck
that's okay cuz I'm gonna get crueler
what oh yeah I don't know what that
means exactly
johnny-boy me ball ball for me
OOP sure sugar da come on huh oh my god
this is too much
I give me a ball where's that ball oh my
god come on come on come on come on come
on come on okay rally team oh my god
love another
aah I thought I'd got that oh I need an
Michael streak hot damn it churro is
doing nothing it's doing nothing for our
team that older guy is doing almost
nothing stop get back you're Michael
stirrer kata
that is unfortunate that they get stuck
but I'm gonna assume that my team is
also god damn it Karl
i'ma just end a little bit in the
discount booth oh I'm s out of the disco
what did you just pass that to him what
what happened don't even know
okay Karl oh that's Carrie not caught
I'm calling your Karl anyway too bad if
you want to be caught Carrie shouldn't
kill me all the stops hey John Johnny
boy all right I can still win this come
on guys I'm pulling this whole game by
myself
hi Karl my name is cut up Karl
your name's Karl now oh it's such a
close game my team actually gotta kill
that snitch
oh I thought I would have gotten a
double oh did I just kill the hunt team
mate I have no idea so boom your kill
run away from me Karl
oh I can win it oh I can win it aah Oh
get back here yeah I thought you had a
ball win this all by myself
yeah girl yeah
ha 20 kills all me it's row like a loser
dying all over the place
oh that game would squat all right
that's enough that's enough that's okay
so that was disco dodgeball amazingly
fun I can't even describe how much fun
this game is you got to play for
yourself playing on the website it's
totally free you want to support them
float them for green light and also you
can buy the early access 5 bucks
that's all there is I think so thank you
all so much for watching as always I
will see you
you